With a legendary career spanning nearly 60
years, Jack Nicholson is considered one of
Hollywood's all-time greats.
But the award-winning actor hasn't appeared
in a movie since 2010, meaning fans only get
to see him when he pops up at award shows.
So what's up with the actor's disappearance?
Well, if you think you can handle the truth,
keep on watching to find out why we don't
hear from Jack Nicholson anymore.
His last film was a bomb
Nicholson's last film, 2010's How Do You Know,
should have been great.
It boasted an all-star cast including Paul
Rudd, Reese Witherspoon and Owen Wilson while
reuniting Nicholson with Terms of Endearment
and As Good As It Gets writer and director
James L. Brooks.
However, the film was a critical failure and
a box office bomb, earning just over $48 million
worldwide against a budget of $120 million.
At the age of 80, Nicholson has to really
want to be in a film these days to bother
- and with his last movie being such a disappointing
experience, it's no wonder he's shied away
from movies ever since.
"You do not have the luxury of not hearing
this"
"God are you gonna make me literally run from
bad news?
"The board has dec-..."
Memory loss
Long gaps between films is actually nothing
new for Nicholson.
As he's gotten older, he's frequently taken
long breaks between movies while waiting for
the right project to come along, with four
years transpiring between As Good As It Gets
and The Pledge, and three years between Something's
Gotta Give and The Departed.
But in 2013, rumors began swirling that his
current break wasn't caused by a lack of interest,
but instead by the rigors of old age, as Radar
Online reported that Nicholson was suffering
from memory loss.
A source told the tabloid "Jack has memory
issues and can no longer remember the lines
being asked of him."
Not so fast
Reports of Nicholson's supposed memory loss
immediately went viral, sparking a debate
in the media over whether the allegations
were true.
Just a few weeks later, however, a pretty
reliable source came forward saying that Nicholson
was doing just fine.
That source?
Nicholson himself.
Yep, Nicholson sat down for a rare interview
with The Sun and explained that his memory
is
totally fine.
Instead, he chalked up the reason for his
absence to simple boredom with the whole movie
star thing, saying he was enjoying the retired
life.
“I’m not going to work until the day I
die, that’s not why I started this.
I mean, I’m not driven.
I was driven — but I’m not, I don’t
have to be out there any more.
In fact, there’s part of me that never really
liked being out there.
[...] I don’t enjoy it, simple as that.”
And that certainly has the ring of truth.
"you want answers?"
"I think I'm entitled to it."
"You want answers?"
"I want the truth!"
"You can't handle the truth!"
Don't call it a comeback
Given his legendary status, you'd think Nicholson
would pretty much have his pick of movie roles.
And you're right.
In just the past few years, Nicholson has
reportedly turned down offers to appear in
films like The Judge, 42, and Nebraska, with
those roles instead going to Robert Duvall,
Harrison Ford, and Bruce Dern.
He was also involved in St. Vincent before
recommending Bill Murray for the role instead,
and his pal Warren Beatty tried to get him
to star in Rules Don't Apply with no luck.
But his acting days might not be entirely
behind him just yet.
According to Variety, Nicholson is planning
to return to the big screen for a remake of
the German comedy Toni Erdmann, which earned
an Oscar nomination for Best Foreign Feature.
Of course, he's changed his mind before, but
here's hoping we get to see Jack doing his
thing on screen at least one more time.
"Here's Johnny!"
And if not?
Well, considering that Nicholson has appeared
in some of the greatest films of all time,
and given us some of the most indelible roles
in movie history, it's clear he has nothing
left to prove to anyone - least of all himself.
All we can say is, thanks, Jack.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!